herzlich willkommen hier zu einem video
was ich viele mal gewünscht haben zwar
passt sich ja meistens immer bei ich
poste sehr oft bei twitter irgendwas
über snap chat und weiter und so fort
und dann habe ich jetzt auch mal gesagt
ja ich heiße das netz von crafter habe
ich mir so ein account gemacht maps in
senden können wir wahrscheinlich schon
seht ich habe hier wasser ich habe
freunde ach nee das ist dieses hier
schon seht war ich da noch nicht so drin
ich habe auch hier links war das plus
das sind alles sachen die mir bisher zu
gesendet wurden weil ich letztes mal
gesagt hat das kann sein dass sie gar
nicht so lang gespeichert werden weil
ich hatte mir jetzt noch nicht
angeschaut aber hier ist trotzdem nichts
da warte ich guck mal was hat mir selber
geschrieben
jetzt seid ihr alle beautiful hoffe dass
bezogen ja keine ahnung ich hatte mir
gedacht ich gehe einfach mal so ein paar
snacks durch das ja blöd wir wurden ja
eigentlich richtig viele so geschickt
also das hat hier gar kein ende hier
unten
aber ich kann mir gar nicht anschauen
die sind irgendwie wohl gelöscht worden
oder so also ich werde mir jetzt einfach
anschauen live mit euch wir fangen jetzt
mal an christoph fischer ja und fünf
äpfel beantworten wir doch mal dort dann
packen wir das hier schön hin noch ein
schönfelder drauf sagt man habe den
standort 36 official hat mir was
geschrieben ok der hat das geschrieben
für fische sondern live video mit dem
machen
live video mit einem fan ich kann nicht
mehr es auch bleiben
verdammt entweder online
was antwortet der christoph fischer der
stadt gar nichts er ist bestimmt schon
scheinbar der bei bild gehört werden
konnte
jetzt habe ich ja auch noch nach
hinbekommen dann schauen wir was am ende
noch hier gespielt
luca makowsky es ist ein bisschen so wie
dieses elfi challenge stieß damals mal
gab dass irgendein youtuber celtics
enden könnte der youtuber muss die
nachmachen ich heule vor lachen
wer dich du geschrieben hat bei diesem
auge leichlinger bestimmte meine
nachbarin ihren pass metal vodka das
hätte ja gut an
hans lanz an das hatte noch geschick
transformers 3 webler camaro
da hast du ein baby love is like i stop
talking cure
das ist eine rolle der diggers cool af
das erste mal auf das erste mal nach as
[ __ ] sowas wie erhält school as [ __ ]
oder gar keinen sinn aber ich weiß auf
jeden fall jetzt heißt okay gut ich
möchte natürlich nicht die obersten
nehmen aber guck mal hier unten da steht
vor einer minute
lisa-marie 792 einer minute den rest
kann ich schon gar nicht mehr anschauen
da steht vor zwei minuten habe ich mir
noch nicht alle angeschaut hier
es ist doch das kann es sein dass ihn
alle gelöscht werden so ob ich noch mal
lernen müsste ja nee also wenn ich das
nächste mal folgten am besten bei
twitter weil hier bringt es nichts wenn
das alles gelöscht wird das heißt am
besten bei twitter folgen da schreibe
ich immer kurz vor seiner dings halt
einfach war nicht wenn ich das dann halt
mache da müsstet mir dann schnell
wachsenden schlecht nicht stinkt mir ein
bild von mir das ist wundervoll es nicht
auch eine antwort hier so sieht das so
genau so aus ich weiß nicht schick ich
immer oh larry der kuki schickt mir ein
video
okay das etwa ich will mir das anschauen
das video tipp umzuladen das geht
einfach nicht entziehen friday weil ich
auf dem video der ist das ist traurig
wenn ihr mich gar nicht sehen können
einen schönen abend
herz- herz die wird bestimmt gut
schlafen können
mary lou reed kriegsheld inderin gewicht
rede ich nur wieder lud special
ich finde es nicht klappt kann ich mir
schon wieder nicht runterladen die
scheiße hier was ist denn da als fax
captured alter und habe ich kollegin
seiten am arm neuen kollegen verletzt
als der sturm afl hier war konnte der
was darauf spielen nachdem habe ich die
ganze zeit versucht mir das auch bei zu
bringen wir schon ob sich diese krawatte
das soll dieses bam bam bam bam bam bam
bam von seven nation army das wollte ich
auf jeden fall mal lernen irgendwann
also ist dieses bamm bamm bamm bamm bamm
bamm bamm
es ist ja nicht so schwer also der wii 2
345 einfach mal langeweile lizenziert
hinten das kennzeichen dann kriegt ihr
mini-tief von wir natürlich auch ins
netz wo ich was zensiere so da habe ich
jetzt auch mal was zensiert das bekommt
die db 2 345 informiert zugeschickt dann
auch die eleganten screenshot gemacht
short aktiviert das ganze nie wieder
machen nachdem dieses bild gesehen hat
luca conny ich glaube all believe i can
fly ich schreibe morgen drei arbeiten
bitte gib mir ein paar tipps gebe mein
tipp für dich wenn das seine arbeit ist
ja es ist immer so abartig viele diese
scheiß bringe ich jetzt mit zu dem video
days dadurch reingebissen das nein nein
das nachdenkt dass wege welche dass das
irgendeinen geben ein dass das
verschwindet jetzt im müll des bildes
aber an sich eigentlich ganz so schlecht
geworden
also ich denke das ist der beste tipp
den ich gehe immer für möglich so
gegeben aber schauen ob die sich darüber
freuen wird so was hatte die thereser
geschrieben wie gc coni und immer
schauen was sie hier
die aus not often low tech welt nicht
mit dem ich heißt es
die folge spuckt alle die dann immer
wieder mal nach cordula was doch nur
dein handy vorsprungs da ist oben ist
tropfen darauf sitzt tropfen also da
sagen wir ja immer viele hart du hast
ist nur so aus die gleichauf schon
kopfschmerzen - ausrasten von soll ein
spiel bekommt neue nachrichten neue neue
snaps wir müssen uns mal wieder ein paar
jahren schon so alina meister
das ist sehr hübsch geworden oder also
mein song doppelkinn kommt bald in die
läden
ich müsste echt noch immer seien nicht
dass sie gleich wieder irgend sondern
seine anhand einer tür klopft wie das
letzte hai luca de mail das sieht ja
nahezu alles neu die wäre der ein rohr
das einzige was ist wenn mein legos
kaputt gegangen das jetzt nicht so doof
bei dings zu zeigen mit meiner fans kann
kann ich euch das einfach hier mit
snapshot tigers hat ihm gefallen und
dieser mechanismus abgebrochen
aber naja um ihren was cooles trotz des
netten werde ich einfach mal das ganze
hier kurz moment mein gott das ist so
zeger die schlechteste nachmache die ich
davon hätte machen können ich mal aber
als einfach hier soll
reaper genommen der steve einfach in hmb
love to entertain you to beachtet faktor
war das noch mal von den alten kombi
schickt es einfach mal an alle
dann können die das bestimmt auch an
mich selbst und an teams napster sehr
wichtig mal wieder so eine vollbelegung
minecraft ist die erste folge eines
relativ viel spaß gemacht ich werde bei
der zweiten folge mehr kassen und das
ganze dann noch 56 minuten halten
wenn das nicht so ein snap vom
contractor parallel sei witzig dem wirst
dich bestimmt jetzt mal auf youtube
abonnieren oh wie süß dir mein herz
geschickt ist echt knuffig doch was gibt
sie sonst noch was die kann ich mir
wieder runterladen hier die scheiße was
soll denn das ich habe das alles hier
nicht runterladen obwohl das gerade erst
es ist doch echt traurig ich kann mir
einfach keinen sex mehr anschauen weil
der die nicht runterladen will was ist
denn los hier mit snapshot sorgt a nice
nice nice besser hätte ich mich nicht
treffen können dann kriegt ihr hier noch
so ein den smiley christi noch jeder der
rutscht dann hier bevor seite rollen
moment hier mal in dieses bild vom ja
ich weiß ja nicht wie es für euch jetzt
ist wenn ihr euch das anschauen aber
mögt ihr solche videos so ruhig dass
eventuell mal öfters machen mit snapshot
oder so mit euch interagieren
weil ich weiß wie viel macht spaß aber
ich weiß nicht ob das schreiben erst mal
nach einem blöden tagen erst mal könig
videos gucken
das ist die devise eigentlich müsste ich
damit das video beenden ich bin dem
neuen snapper senden überführte ich bin
das team bei
anbot was haben wir noch mal gut 1 2 3 4
das ist total schlechter service ja kein
ding das nehme ich da natürlich an
botschafter du bist cool das ist die
message des tages für den kongress der
welt gebeten das alter diese cinderella
schickt mir mit einem und einem okay das
ist ein wundervoller snap ich mal noch
eben kurz mint zahn rausguckt als böse
diesem papier da muss man diesem papier
was habe ich da wieder wie dem vampir
mache ich da unten rauskommen so wir den
fehler nie wieder sehen hier würdest du
mit einem fan befreundet sein wollen was
jetzt hier ist eine fragerunde oder was
welch zufall ein snap den ich mir nicht
runterladen kann das ist ja helaba
ein screenshot gemacht new taste für
milch getrunken
ich habe überlegt was ich auch immer für
eine scheiße wieso kann ich das denn
nicht runterladen
sein bester freund ist ein baum brot ich
bin raus das ist doch nicht wahr was ist
denn das tier wieder für eine scheiße
die mir gesendet wird week at schickt
mir vanille cola g shock fucking bttv
voll nachgemacht form einer
geschmackvoll nachgekauft kritik sollte
sich lieber arshad nennen das mit viel
mehr
übrigens freunde das ist alles nur hier
spaß was ich hier mache auch wenn ich
ans netz sein oder so das sind immer
viele so direktor der hat gesagt meine
katze sagt hallo herr wundervoll noch
ins netz von hier
sie hatten kontrollieren konnte
täglich direkt land wollte red
komm wir machen konnten semikolon hier
raus das ist doch das orgateam das
scheiße aus übrigens falls ihr euch
einen t shirt girl tier findet in der
beschreibung link wenn ihr euch das kauf
möchtet letztes hat übrigens der erste
das wollte sagen dass du mich mit deinem
videos jeden tag zum lachen bringt ich
wollte dir sagen danke der junge keine
ahnung wie ich denke mal das wort weil
die restlichen netz wenn ich drauf
klickt kann ich mir nicht runterladen
das packt mich grad ein bisschen ab und
chatten oder sind noch welche kommen
jetzt machen wir mal eine durch ballerei
julia heil uta ich gehe als den ihn
alois nee ich guck galileo und sma
cashback product placement wer stefanie
china die flut wenn du dir stehen trust
ssl die muss lernen
alexandra die halo aus bielefeld xl das
ist doch nicht war als ob mir hier nur
mädels in welches netz schinken mir ist
langweilig bei derart vader läuft ich
glaube jetzt haben den absoluten
tiefpunkt erreicht
ich schaue mir noch kurz die beiden
snaps von lisa maria 97 und lena style
titel fertig wird behindert ja die
ganzen anderen snaps ihr seht ihr ja
diese wurden auch jetzt alle irgendwie
vor 21 minuten vor 20 minuten also das
video ist jetzt auch razzien 24 minuten
wahrscheinlich wieder runter kürzen kann
ich mir aber nicht mehr anschauen sonst
sind hier die ganze zeit nur so
nachrichten wie er rein kommt man
schnell in meine story damit dass alle
sehen video vorbei damit mir keiner was
posten nicht noch mal zeigen ja mach das
mal dann habt ihr habe ich jetzt auch
eine geschichte wie die hof vorbei das
ist ihr könnt mich glaube ich alle
retten oder zumindest allen snaps
ähnlich heiß aufs netz von crafter
vielleicht hat euch gefallen wenn sie es
getan hat würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freund schaffen wir
fünfstellige bewertungen in die 10.000
oder so für meinen schnitt keine ahnung
wie viel ich das schreiben werde aber
wenn ich wieder sehr das video geht eine
halbe stunde
wenn ich wahrscheinlich eine menge
schneiden bank würde ich sagen sehen uns
dann im nächsten video wieder wenn es
wieder gut